[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity anti-trump FBI agent Peter
struck has been subpoenaed to testify
before a public joint hearing of the
House Judiciary and oversight committees
next Tuesday
but according to Struck's attorney Peter
struck may not comply with the subpoena
watch this will your client comply with
the subpoena or the request Willy come
on in and do another interview my client
will testify publicly soon somewhere
sometime we just got this subpoena today
so I don't know whether or not we are
going to be testifying next Tuesday in
front of these two particular House
subcommittees why isn't it an automatic
yes a time because we have come to the
conclusion we've been forced to come to
the conclusion that this is not a search
for truth it is a chance for Republican
members of the House to preen and
posture before their most radical
conspiracy minded constituents joining
me now with reaction is House Oversight
Chairman South Carolina congressman trey
Gowdy he's the author of look with the
senator Tim Scott called unified and
Trey thank you so much for joining us
tonight some conspiracy theories he was
talking about that we get the
Republicans to you know buy into this
stuff but I want to play a clip from
Adam Schiff talking to that you were one
of the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
so play this clip here sadly here we
have all too many members of Congress
willing to prostrate themselves before
the executive and give him anything he
wants you want to name names which
members of Congress are in this cult
like a group that you that you're
suggesting you know the Four Horsemen of
this apocalypse have been Devin Nunez
and trey Gowdy the Mark meadows and Jim
Jordan they have been leading the charge
basically to require the Justice
Department to give them materials that
can be leaked or fed or misrepresented
like the infamous Nunez memorandum in
the service of the president interesting
comments for mr. Schiff mr. Gowdy how
many times have you met and interacted
with Donald Trump I've never met
President
never had a conversation with him I
didn't want to get too struck impatient
in a second but with Jason initially I
took that as a compliment I'm a huge Ric
Flair fan so anytime somebody says
you're part of the Four Horsemen I
thought it was a compliment it was my
wife who later said I think he's talking
about those four guys from the book of
Revelation so that's not a compliment
let me tell you this about Adam Adams
had a terrible last couple of years he
wanted to be the Attorney General under
Hillary Clinton and no one in the
country worked harder to protect her
than Adam Schiff he wanted to be the
head of the CIA he wanted to run for
California and the run for Senate and
the People's Republic of California but
he couldn't win either of those seats so
now now he wants to be the chairman of
the House Intelligence Committee
speaking of the Apocalypse Adam Schiff
wants to be the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee if you ever have
I don't know a couple of free months
with nothing else to do I want you to go
back Jason and think of all the things
you would not know if you had taken Adam
shifts advise you wouldn't know the
whole spontaneous reaction to a video
was a hoax and Lybia you would never
have read the first Chris Stevens email
you wouldn't know that Hillary Clinton
had this unique email arrangement with
herself because Adam Schiff did
everything in his power to keep you from
finding out you wouldn't know about the
dossier you wouldn't know who funded it
you wouldn't know it was used in a court
proceeding you wouldn't know about
struck in Page in fact you wouldn't even
be having a show tonight you wouldn't be
having the show about struck and Paige
if Adam Schiff had had his way so look
if they secede from the union and
President Maxine Waters wants to make
him the Attorney General in California
more power to it otherwise I don't think
anybody on my side of the aisle give us
much of a damn what Adam Schiff things
well he certainly gets out there and
says it a lot whatever is he's saying
but he has I think misled and misused
that position for my own personal
vantage point time and time again now
coming before you though is this Peter
struck as I recall he originally said he
would voluntarily testify that he wanted
to get out and tell his story but then
you heard his attorney in that clip say
that he may not show up well I'm
certainly sorry if anyone hurt his
feelings last week during the 13 hours
we
but but the only thing I did was go over
what he had written so if he's offended
he's offended with things that he wrote
he wrote a lot of texts there are emails
it's an unprecedented level of animus so
of course he's going to be asked what
did you mean I can't use all of the
words on a family friendly show like
yours but what did you mean by blanking
abysmal what did you mean by blanking
this I we went through all of his texts
here's what's important Jason he's
supposed to be investigating Hillary
Clinton for potential violations of the
Espionage Act in March of 2016 when he's
supposed to be investigating her he
hadn't even interviewed her yet he
thinks that she should win the
presidency 100 million to zero Jason she
wasn't even the nominee at the time they
didn't even have a Republican nominee at
the time but she's gonna win a hundred
million to zero in March of 2016 and
this according to the guy who's supposed
to be dispassionately and objectively
interviewing her then in July when the
Russia probe started he is saying
terrible things about the very person
he's supposed to be objectively
investigating and then we get till the
mama probe you know I mean he's been
told all three Hillary Clinton Russia
probe Muller probe until they found his
text he's talking about impeachment even
before the House Democrats and MSNBC
were talking about impeachment he had
been on the case three days before he's
already talking about impeaching the
president so of course we're gonna have
a lot of questions for him and some of
them might actually be uncomfortable but
he's gonna come before a public hearing
whether his lawyer thinks he is or not
he's coming I'm sure he would rather go
in front of Adam Schiff that that's what
I read he'd rather go in front of Adam
Schiff they got a lot in common they
both wanted Hillary Clinton to be
President I get why he wants to go there
but he's gonna come before our two
committees whether he wants to or not
well you know look Peter struck did not
have an insignificant job as like I like
to say he didn't work for the Fish &
Wildlife Department he was the number
two person and counterintelligence for
the United States Federal Bureau of
Investigation they have tens of
thousands of people to choose from have
you been able to find out why is it that
he was selected or appointed to go
beyond the Muller probe well you got to
go all the way back to Clinton he was on
the Clinton probe and then in July not
only was the only Russia Pro premolar he
was the lead agent on the Russia probe
premolar so in July of 2016 we just got
through Jim Comey with that
unprecedented press conference in three
weeks later he's working on Donald
Trump's campaign and the Russia probe I
think that group was then transposed
over on till the Russia probe and then
they many of them were transposed over
on till the Muller probe I will give him
all her credit for this the moment he
found out about these texts he got rid
of Peter struck but here's what you
ought to be asking yourself if it was
bad enough for Bob Mulder to get rid of
him the moment he found out about the
text these texts weren't written in
March of 2017 they were written in March
of 2016 so he never should have been on
any of these three probes
if the animus was enough to kick him off
when you found it the animus should have
been enough to kick him off when he said
it which was early in 2016
completely the wrong person the FBI's
reputation look there are lots and lots
of fantastic FBI agents 99.9% of them
but to pick this person at not just town
Lisa page and other heretofore not
identified FBI agents you remember when
Jim called me I think you were in the
committee room when Jim Comey said the
FBI didn't give a hoot about politics
yeah go read these text they gave a lot
more than a hoot about who was going to
be the Democratic nominee and whether
Donald Trump would win well real quickly
because I only got a few seconds Lisa
Paige was on the other end of those
texts what's gonna happen with her she's
coming too I mean I heard your guests
that we're all before me Jason I just
disagree with them I think anytime you
have a chance to spend 12 hours will the
witness you all to spend it I get five
minutes with Peter struck any public
hearing yeah I got ten hours with him
last week so we're gonna interview her
and then I hope we have a public hearing
with her but it's more important to me
that all these questions get asked on
the record talked about I mean if you
want a serious investigation pick the 10
hours over the 5 minutes is what I would
tell my fellow citizens and they need to
get the documents from the Department of
Justice trey Gowdy
thank you so much for joining us tonight